normal people become terrified of
criminals shots are just fired police
just came out and told us and we're
headed there right now they become
terrified of their own government
officer involved shooting in Martinsburg
results in suspect taking his own life
this is YouTuber Hunter evalon he's been
a guest on this show he's a political
commentator he uh was with his
girlfriend her ex showed up attempting
to I I it would appear to kill Hunter
evalon and ended up shooting his ex and
then when police arrived on scene and uh
uh this is uh this was West Virginia
State Police this is I believe the
Martinsburg uh City police as well as I
think I'm hearing rumors even Harper's
Ferry may have responded maybe after the
fact they uh there's there's Hunter
posted the video you you you can't see
anything you can hear the uh uh the
gunshots uh I I I don't know exactly
what happened the guy apparently had a
shotgun and uh yeah so let me I'll show
you this tweet this is from Hunter I I
want to say this I mean you you know you
got to be a bit in the weeds to know uh
Hunter Avalon he's he's a political
commentator but you know it's not I'm
not trying to be a dick or anything he's
not the biggest political commentator
but he has been on the show before and
we we had no idea he lived like two
buildings down from us from uh our
Martinsburg building where this is where
we're building the coffee shop it's
where we're building the the skate shop
so this is this is local news to us and
uh he tweet he he tweeted this I'm still
trying to process this and I'm most
likely in shock as I write this but only
a few hours ago Holly's boyfriend Conrad
shut up at my apartment building with a
shotgun he shot through my building door
injuring Holly's leg in the process I
recorded the final moments in which we
were hiding on the back porch you can
hear him shoot at police before
ultimately taking his own life in my own
effing apartment hallway I'm still
trying to process process this Holly and
I are physically okay but mentally this
is going to do some serious damage
Holly's been amazing and she's been
incredibly brave and strong throughout
this ordeal he posted uh this he said
this was Conrad's final text message
with Holly after she'd been injured she
said please surrender I'm losing a lot
of blood the shooter responds I never
meant that no godamn it leave him please
said only if you surrender and said I
will just live your life for yourself
and then he says I should have killed
the coward so when firing through that
door it appears the the it this guy went
to Hunter's house to to kill him and uh
there there there's more to this I mean
there's a lot of reasons why I just you
know what
man first and foremost I'll just say it
this way uh I I'm I I the reports from
the police are that they went to the
hospital it's it's superficial injuries
looks like Hunter's girlfriend's going
to be okay so I'm glad to hear that I uh
uh sent him a message you know but he
should take care of himself whatever
he's a couple uh buildings down from us
but this is this is this is crazy and
you know for us for me why I why I think
this is so important I mean it's
important you guys take security
seriously it's important you guys
understand uh the right to keep in bear
arms that's right uh Hunter should not
have been he should he should not have
been hiding on his back porch uh I mean
maybe he should have I don't know he's
in West Virginia I just got to say man
he should he should have a weapon I
don't know what else to say I don't know
I mean I think that we live in a time
that we have to understand that not only
is there a massive amount of mental
illness that's you know kind of going
around but we also have to acknowledge
that there's really been this kind of
devaluation on human life I mean you're
starting to see this callous approach to
where taking you know human lives mean
absolutely nothing and so I think that
we live in a day and age and
unfortunately that we should and uh I I
would encourage people to be able to
defend their own homes to understand
stand your ground and understand your
Castle Law to understand you know the
ability to try and protect your family
which is ultimately our inalienable
right under our Second Amendment right
so and and this is why I you know every
every argument made by every anti-gun
anti-2a person is going to be like that
man should not have had a gun a good
luck man that's such a ridiculous
argument crazy guy is going to find a
weapon you can 3D print them right so
I'm not I'm not here to cast anything on
Hunter I'm not saying he did anything
wrong I'm just saying you know I hope I
hope in the future he looks to his his
personal defense for his home he's in a
constitutional carry state he can do it
and uh and he should and but but I am I
am glad the police were there and uh uh
were able to look I mean I always give
the most uh Kudos ever to our First
Responders who are just amazing people I
mean these are the individuals that run
towards fire when everyone's running you
know running away these are the people
that run towards gunfire when other
people are running away I mean just The
Bravery of our men and women in in
uniform I I just don't think it can be
understated and how much we should
appreciate what they do dude you
mentioned the Deval of human life that's
kind of been a trend and I I was just
talking to Dr Drew earlier on my show
and interviewed it was great talk we
talked about narcissism it came up and
like I was like what does that mean that
means I love myself cuz like in like no
no no means like when you're a kid and
it becomes like your your bonding
mechanisms become a threat so you go
Inward and you like kind of soothe
Yourself by ignoring others and then you
start to lose he explained it way better
he wrote a book on it but like I don't
know if it's the age if it's the if it's
the internet all the video games people
are diving into as kid if it's being
kids set in front of a YouTube for three
hours when the mom's in the kitchen just
doing whatever if it's the drugs like
the Pharmaceuticals that kids are like
moms on amphetamines that are giving
birth to kids that have like hard time
their gut biomes that's all of it and I
think it's all of it I think it's a
culmination of like so many things not
to mention the fact that you have 22 23
year olds who've never knew America
without being at a time of War I mean
yeah what's that about Man the War
weariness what is that like a kid is
told like this is normal this is what we
are and it's like but that's horrible to
be I mean in my opinion conquest and
colonization of Iraq Afghan attempted
Afghanistan Syria Libya like it's
disgusting I don't it's just for oil as
far as I can tell or for resources but
like to be told like this is how it is
Hell welcome to the greatest country on
Earth we're conquesting all these other
countries oh but the problem is is like
we were talking about before the show
started I mean you've got this kind of
neoconservative neoliberal like liberal
kind of interventionist mindset where
they think that all of our you know
Warfare is still based in a kinetic
realm of gun to gun bomb to bomb bullet
to bullet and they completely ignore the
fact that the evolution of warfare is
now into the non-kinetic kind of
information Warfare propaganda Warfare
you know economic resource supply chain
and cyber I mean these are the areas
that we need to be focusing on and I'm
look I'm not an interventionist but I'm
not isolationist right we we need to be
protectionist and understand though that
there's certain things that have nothing
to do with us you know I would look at
Ukraine as one of the biggest models of
that and so for me you know the reasons
why we went into Iraq which lost you
know almost a million plus innocent
lives no no one you know I've spent
seven years of my life in Iraq I spent
almost three years of my life in
Afghanistan Kosovo Pakistan uh North
Somalia all these areas one of the
things that I've learned is that any
government at the end of War can try and
claim a victory but no one wins when it
comes to war you're always going to have
certain amounts of collat damage you're
always going to have certain people are
going to lose their life who shouldn't
you're always going to make sure that
you're going to lose some of someone's
brothers and and and uncles and fathers
and husbands and things like this in
these wars and so we need to stop
treating lives as if we're pawns on a
chess board somewhere that we can just
basically move to play political
football we have to be smart in how we
not only protect our American people but
we protect our treasures and we protect
our ability to be able to be strong
again we have to get America First
agenda back on the Block and we have to
stop this interventionist mindset of the
1980s I watched I think it was Clint
Russell retweeted this is from a few
days ago some graphic of like veteran
suici how the deaths of uh active
military and it's like suicide is like
15 18% in 1980 and then it goes up and
over the years and now it's at like 45%
of active the does that work what
in the hell and that's just people that
are actually there in the military
getting I also contribute that to a
little bit of the wokeness that's
basically continued to try and utilize
this indoctrinating kind of uh process
where in our military you know one one
of the things that we strived so hard
for myself Matt Gates Jim Banks Ronnie
Jackson I mean so many of the members of
our armed services committee and
especially the mil Pur subcommittee was
to get away from this idea that
meritocracy no longer can exist and it's
all about the diversity equity and
inclusion the Dei you know what we
really need to be focusing on for our
military which is what it used to be
focused on is things like increased
lethality Readiness and being properly
equipped you know those are the three
things I want to see out of my military
and I think that what we're bringing in
now is what drag shows and you
transsexual you know uh agender
affirming surgeries and travel abortion
that's being paid for by the federal
government things like this that in no
way I mean what we should be thinking
about is how do we improve the quality
of life how do we get military
Construction milcon in place that allows
the housing availability and
affordability to be better for our our
Armed Forces how can we actually make
sure that instead of just having two
days a week for child care for the
spouses of those who serve we have it
all day every day so they can have
careers of their own like we should be
thinking about improving the quality of
life of our armed service members but
also let's start prioritizing our
veterans over illegal aliens who are
basically invading our nation I mean not
because American culture has shifted
into being sort of anti-military I think
that there's sort of a a a disconnect
between the way people used to feel I
mean this Administration has almost
become anti-American oh they're they're
100% anti not even Amic anti military
day-to-day American person personality I
mean you see this reflected in military
recruitment recruitment people don't
want to join the
military, recruit deficit right now I
mean you're talking three military
divisions yeah and meanwhile one of the
Amendments that I tried to pass that I
tried to put in that CBO the
Congressional budget office try to say
scored which is nonsense I wanted us to
basically look at the fact that these
vaccination purging is unconstitutional
and that we should bring back our
military service members we should give
them the back pay that's necessary they
shouldn't have to pay any bonuses back
because at the end of the day they were
to serve our government to I should say
serve our nation not to serve our
government's agenda and so you know and
meanwhile they like no sorry this scores
so you can't put it in as an amendment
it's it it it's just ridiculous what
we're seeing right now I I I guess I I
have to agree to some extent it is an
anti-military but
anti-American think there's a way to
shift culture away from that I mean
there's always going to be politicians
who are sort of anti-military or see you
know more conservative takes on the
military and conservative values uh a as
a threat but do the day-to-day Americans
ultimately want to say oh you're
returning vet I don't care about you
because that's really what a lot of you
said the exact thing in the earlier part
of your statement which is politicians
they're part of the they're actually the
biggest part of the problem we don't
need politicians we need Statesmen we
need veterans who've actually served in
uniform who understand exactly what our
war Fighters need to be able to move
forward we have to have the necessary
resources and assets not being
pre-allocated to another country to
where they can actually worry about the
PTSD and the the trauma the other
nations going through and ignoring our
own veterans here at home we have to
just get back to Statesmen who
understand what the America first
approach is and start prioritizing the
American citizens uh we had Tom sour on
a couple days ago and he's like
privatized he's taking it into his own
hands they have a private company it's
mirar health and they're wholly focused
on helping veterans rehabilitate
themselves through whatever kind of
therapy whether it's psych I think
they're they're they're looking into um
Psy psychedelic therapy as well like
MDMA it's a lot of it's about
communication about and I I I don't
think the government can handle it I
think it needs to be in the private
sector like the VA
I don't know a lot about it but all I
hear complaints about complaints for 20
years people have been complaining about
how ineffective it is so I'm I don't
know if you it is in effective and you
know I'll even go a step further you
you'll the problem with all of
government is that the metric of success
is completely skewed their idea by
gauging what is a metric of success is
the idea of how much should I spend and
they continue to try and say oh well we
spent more this year than we'd ever
spent before Oh we increased veterans by
you know 20% oh we did this what they're
not doing is is gauging it by the true
metric of how many people did you
actually help what is the outcome in
which we're looking at where we're able
to say we went from 21 or 22 veteran
suicides today down to 18 what was that
cost in order to do that because let me
tell you if I could get it down to zero
give me that number you know but you
also have them where they'll go ahead
and say oh we just built another VA
Hospital well yeah you just spent a
billion dollars on this new VA hospital
in a metropolitan area that already has
nine other hospitals which have the same
exact levels of care why wouldn't you
put that to a rural area where people
can actually get treatment and open it
up to where all of our veterans can
basically utilize the existing you know
uh Medical Treatments and Facilities
that are actually existing there already
I mean this is the thing veterans don't
necessarily need to have like a special
hospital we there's hospitals who offer
a lot of these same things but we do
need them in the rural communities we do
need to understand how do we treat and
how do we give the necessary resources
and assets I mean the the military
veteran as a whole is very traditional
you know we believe in things like being
able to as as a man for example the idea
to be able to protect my family to be
able to provide for my family and so
when we come out and we essentially have
no way to supply and you know keep up
with the 40-year high inflation and the
cost of living that's out of control and
untenable or we don't have the housing
affordability and availability for a
soldier any longer and so they don't
feel like a MM because they can't
protect and provide for their family so
that loses their their their objective
their mission their focus and I think
that then they start chasing you know
well something must be wrong I'm getting
into a depressed state and here's the
other problem that we have to
acknowledge the far tical companies have
continued just with the doctors to want
to overprescribe and over medicate every
single person think that that's the
solution the benefit when you're sick
and they can prescribe you something for
all the side effects that they have
caused but they want to keep you sick
for as long as possible because that's
how they actually make they benefit when
you're sick is that how it is in the VA
too it's exactly how it is oh you have
an issue here's a script oh that Pain's
still bothering you and that the last
pain pills that we didn't give you is
enough let me increase the dosage you
know and I'm not saying that we don't
have great Medical Care Providers but
what we do have is we've got a conflict
of interest when you have people who
actually are able to you know it's the
same thing with you know legislators who
are able to trade in the stock market
even though they can make legislation
that manipulates the stock price you
have doctors who of course are going to
invest in the pharmaceutical companies
of the you know things that they
prescribe the most right because they
understand so there there's just a lot
that we have to fix in this country but
the first thing is we have to get back
to understanding what does it mean to be
on an America First agenda again mhm
would you recommend joining the military
to like an 18-year-old today you know I
would I mean look at the end of the day
we've got one of the strongest greatest
volunteer forces I was proud to have
served in uniform and I think it's a
great honor I think it's something that
if you're born with that servant
leadership heart and a lot of us you
know we used said joke that we must be
wired wrong right but the reality is
that you're just born with a servant
leadership heart you are or you're not
and the thing that why I ran you know
one of the big things was not just to
look out for our military veterans but
to ensure that our military has all the
nation you know the resources the assets
and that they get back to the priorities
that they should be focused on so that
men and women can actually serve not
thinking about this woke agendo or this
Dei over meritocracy type of thing for
you know Equity over equality I mean
it's it's just this idea of us building
back our military on the principles and
the beliefs of what it originally
started from I want to introduce a super
soldier program where people can you can
be like youo you want to do experimental
gene therapy and be able to run three
times faster not have to breathe breathe
every eight eight minutes you want to
see 90 times further I feel like you're
volunteering for it right that's what
I'm talking about dude I will be the
first and like I but I think so many
young people maybe don't have a purpose
and like the idea that you could become
a badass and it would be it's all on you
though cuz it may may not work it may
work but like you can sign up for this I
think it would increase we have the
X-Men I guess at some point that's what
I'm talking about it's because it's
happening anyway man in China they're
doing crisper they are building super
soldiers so why don't we just do it
publicly we don't have to disclose all
the results I I honestly just wish we
could even get back to the idea of not
having drag shows on our military
installation so you're you're Lighty
years ahead on that already you mention
I was going to say I feel like because
recruitment uh standards are so like
we're not meeting recruitment goals
right now they're more likely to want to
lower all of the physical standards
rather than start recruiting for
potential super soldiers well I mean
look Al maybe you can make a super
soldier out of anybody I don't really
know how it works I always say that you
know one of the things that that that
plagues this nation is that we have a
crisis in leadership and you know the
issues that we're seeing right now yes
it does start at the commander-in-chief
but it also I look at the Secretary of
Defense who I've actually issued
impeachment articles against and filed
those because of his you know handling
and D elction of Duty if you want to on
how Afghanistan went and The Botch
withdraw it cost 13 Brave Heroes their
lives and and I'm blessed that I'll be
I'll be with paos who is the mother of
Ryan canos one of the 13 uh brave
soldiers who had died on August 26th
I'll be with her December 13th where uh
we'll be going out in in section 60 in
Arlington to be able to go ahead and
visit her son and pay our respects but
you know there has to be accountability
again in government that's what it
matters Floyd Austin Secretary of
Defense and did he oversee the surrender
he oversaw a majority of it thanks for
watching this clip from the timcast IRL
podcast hang out with us live Monday
through Friday at 8:00 p.m. and become a
member over at timcast.net